bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches
peut-on faire pire que 2020
bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons vous
parler du bilan de 2020 et des
prospectives 2021
bonjour estelle bonjour olivier bonjour
à tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro
de ses caches on commence la saison avec
un numéro spécial puisque c'est l'heure
olivier de dresser le bilan de cette
année très particulière qui a été 2020
que doit-on retenir dans quel état sont
les indicateurs aujourd'hui à quoi
s'attendre l'année prochaine ce sont
allés différentes questions qui vont
nous occuper ses 26 prochaines minutes
et pour cela tout au long de cette
émission nous serons en liaison comme en
début d'année dernière avec jean marc
daniel bonjour jean marc daniel vous
êtes économiste et professeur à escp
europe merci à d'être parmi nous
aujourd'hui et bienvenue dans ces caches
bonjour et merci de m'avoir invité
alors vous avez sans doute envie de
l'oublier mais on va commencer tout de
même par revivre un peu à les faits
marquants de cette année dernière une
année il faut l'avouer à particulière
retour en 2020 avec le tiroir cash
d'antoine face
bon bah voilà 2020 s'est terminée quelle
année mais annick à l'année quelle année
bien pourri web
non mais sérieusement c'était pas
l'année la plus nas qu'on n'ait jamais
eu ça a commencé en janvier avec les
incendies en australie 18 millions
d'hectares brûlés un milliard d'animaux
tués
vous les avez vu les images du petit
koala et bam ça continue le break site
après des mois et des mois de
tergiversations le divorce qu aux uk a
lieu le 31 janvier où passent sur
février et alors là le summum
confinement qu'ovide et tout le tintouin
vous connaissez la musique tout le reste
chez soi n'est connue dégringole le
chômage explose +22 6% en avril chez les
chômeurs de catégorie a les entreprises
qui ferment leurs rideaux l'activité est
ralentie d'environ 30% selon les
estimations du ministère de l'économie
et si pendant quelques semaines d'été on
a eu l'espoir de retrouver une vie à peu
près normale
la deuxième vague la noyée à suivirent
second confinement plus léger certes
mais qui fait quand même mal à
l'économie
au total 2020 aurait vu le pib français
chuté de près de 10%
cerise sur le gâteau le plan de relance
européen censé relancer toute l'union
européenne s'est retrouvé bloqué par le
veto de la hongrie et la pologne
reste maintenant à savoir ce que
voudrait
vera 2021 un vaccin une économie qui
redémarre
ou alors une troisième vague un nouveau
confinement dans le tiroir castres
n'hésitera toute prévision on préfère
vous laisser regarder dans la boule de
cristal de viviers de la marche
nous on dira juste que dans ses
prévisions de l'année dernière locaux
vides
pas même lui il n'avait pas vu venir
voilà pour les grands actes de l'année à
2020 pour commencer jean marc daniel
vous qu'est-ce que vous retiendrez cette
année oui je crois que ce qu'il faut
retenir c'est effectivement là qu vide
c'est à dire c'est un choc que les
économistes qualifient en général l'exo
gêne c'est quelque chose que personne
n'avait vu venir
l'année dernière à la même période nous
annoncions une croissance pour 2020 en
france entre 1,1 et 1,2 pour cent selon
le gouvernement 0 5% pour les plus
pessimistes comme moi vous regardez le
déficit budgétaire qui était annoncé 93
milliards d'euros on va terminer à 220
225 milliards d'euros regardez même une
économie qui supposait avoir bien géré
la crise la chine ont ce n'était plus ou
moins émue de constater que pour la
première fois depuis très longtemps le
taux de croissance de la chine descendre
en dessous de 6% à 5 9%
on va terminer l'année entre 25 et 2 %
donc il était impossible de voir venir
cette maladie en revanche ce qui est le
plus inquiétant c'est effectivement la
façon dont certains pays ont réagi tous
les pays n'ont pas agi de la même façon
et les pays qui ont été les plus frappés
les plus touchés par les conséquences
économiques de la maladie sont quatre
pays européens qui n'ont eu comme
solution que de confiner l'économie je
pense à au royaume uni l'italie et à
l'espagne à la france hors des choix
aurait pu être fait différemment on l'a
vu avec la suède
on l'a vu avec la corée on l'a vu avec
la chine donc un des questionnements
aussi de cette année c est ce que les
décisions publiques la façon de prendre
des décisions en france soit en
conformité avec les exigences du moment
olivier à une réaction même question à
jean marc daniel qu'est-ce que vous
retiendrez cette année justement la même
chose
moi ce qui me ce qui me frappe c'est que
c'est quelque chose tout de même
jean marc a dit on ne pouvait pas le
prévoir
c'est vrai qu'on ne pouvait pas le
prévoir simplement ce que je dis et que
je répète depuis des années c'est que à
cette occasion là toute la poussière
qu'on a et mis sous le tapis
depuis des années à nous a explosé à la
figure
et donc c'est quelque chose on ne savait
pas que ce serait un virus bien
évidemment mais c'est quelque chose qui
de toute façon devait arriver et et ça a
été géré est de la plus mauvaise des
façons par franchement d'aider une
équipe de bras cassés dans ces pays là
dans ces quatre pays européens
on le voit encore maintenant à chaque
fois on a l'impression que ça y est on
s'arrête dans les dents les bêtises ben
non on en rajoute
moi je poserai la question si si on fait
ça pour une maladie qui au final est
très peu létale si vous regardez les
chiffres c'est très peu létale mais
qu'est ce qu'on fera le jour où il y
aura un vrai virus très létale donc on
est dans un an dans quelque chose ou on
voit très bien que les dirigeants ou
absolument perdu la main alors où
ou peut-être en profite il pour cacher
leur incompétence et le que vide va
rester très longtemps probablement le
prétexte à petit et le le conte vide le
vide or a bon dos pendant quelques
années encore et on va on voit bien
qu'il n'ya pas deux il n'y a pas de
reprise possible en 2021 quand je vois
aujourd'hui des des gens qui nous
annonce que en 2022 on aura effacé
l'ardoisé je leur annonce que
malheureusement en 2022 nous n'aurons
pas effacer l'ardoisé que le
les choses sont en train de nous coûter
donc voilà on va bien les mains voilà un
une immense déception parce que on tue
inutilement l'économie alors on va bien
évidemment un reparler tout dans cette
émission du coronavirus cette épidémie
elle nous aura tout de même fait presque
oublier le bric site
le divorce a été à prononcer pourtant
jean marc daniel il reste encore des tas
de choses à régler pour normaliser cette
nouvelle relation que le lieu va devoir
entretenir avec son voisin
d'outre-manche
oui sur le sur le papier il ya encore
énormément de problème vous savez on
était arrivé à une sorte de monstruosité
en termes de texte d'accord qui faisait
plus de 600 pages
en fait on s'aperçoit que il ya trois
éléments qui vont jouer leurs éléments
on va pas s'enfermer et on va pas
rétablir des frontières de nature
autarcique entre le royaume-uni et le
reste de l'union européenne le royaume
uni commerce déjà avec l'union
européenne à hauteur de 50% de son pub
d'enfer de ses deux plus exactement de
son commerce extérieur
on va pas revenir en arrière brutalement
le deuxième enjeu où il se focalise sur
quelques points précis la pêche la
frontière entre l'irlande du nord et la
république d'irlande et ses problèmes et
b ils vont être résolus de façon très
pragmatique et je pense que dire que à
partir du 31 décembre tout va changer ça
ne s'est pas à mon avis aussi évident
que ce qu'on raconte la dernière
éléments c'est quand même que l'économie
britannique est dans une situation qui
est une situation très délicate
indépendamment du prg excite c'est à
dire que l'économie britannique et
accumule les déficits extérieurs c'est
un des plus gros déficit extérieur de la
planète en termes de balance des
paiements courants avec celui des etats
unis
la livre est en train de s'effriter
progressivement par rapport à toutes les
autres monnaies et on ne voit pas de
redressement possible au royaume uni
dans des circonstances où effectivement
le coc vide là aussi la corrida montré
une forme d'un curry de la classe
politique britannique
là des grandes caractéristiques qui fait
l'union européenne en ce moment c'est à
mon avis l'incompétence des dirigeants
des grands pays alors que les pays
intermédiaires je pense aux pays bas je
pense à l'autriche je pense au danemark
sont mieux gérées et le royaume uni
m sortie de l'union européenne n'échappe
pas à cette règle dans une classe
politique qui est dans une fuite en
avant permanente et qui utilise le break
6 pour essayer d'effacer sur le plan
psychologique et sur le plan de la
communication sa propre incurie
olivier vous êtes d'accord avec cette
analyse ah oui je pense que le alors moi
je pense que ils ont les ils auront les
coudées franches
une fois qu'ils seront sortis de l'union
européenne et que s'ils utilisent bien
je dis bien s'ils utilisent bien il
pourrait rebondir beaucoup mieux que
certains pays coincées dans l'union
européenne comme nous par exemple il
était donc pardon s'il utilise bien
s'ils utilisent bien si en effet les
politiques anglais font ce qu'il faut et
non pas et non pas n'importe quoi comme
je vous dis les autres pays qui sont eux
coincés dans l'europe donc qu'il y a une
double incompétence malheureusement pour
nous il ya la nôtre en interne
et puis il ya celle de cette espèce de
petite mafia européenne non élue qui
rajoute de l'incompétence à
l'incompétence ça fait beaucoup
d'incompétence tout ça est l'événement
phare un bien sûr de cette année 2020
c'est évidemment l'arrivée du
coronavirus avec une activité économique
qui a chuté en france de 30 % au 1er
confinement jean marc daniel un tel
ralentissement économique c'est du
jamais vu
ah oui c'est du jamais vu c'est à dire à
un moment donné on a une communication
gouvernementale consiste à dire nous
sommes en guerre alors il faut remonter
effectivement à des situations des
années 40 avec des déficit budgétaire le
plus gros déficit budgétaire de
l'histoire du 20e siècle c'était 1943 40
% de déficit budgétaire
l'art n'est pas arrivé à ces niveaux là
on a atteint un peu plus de 10% déficit
budgétaire cette année est donc un
appauvrissement violent et brutal de la
population qui était lié à la guerre
mais en temps de paix on n'avait jamais
vu ça et c'était assez
évident que ça se terminerait comme ça
pendant 55 jours au premier semestre on
a empêché la population de travailler et
l'a de nouveau pendant une quarantaine
de jours on n'a pas empêché la
population de travailler mais on a mis
des bâtons dans les roues dans un
certain nombre d'activités avec comme
résultat que la contraction était
immédiate est inévitable ce qu'il ya
d'intéressant dans ce qui s'est passé
c'est deux choses la première c'est que
le gouvernement a cru qu'on pouvait
substituer de la dette au travail c'est
le discours de quoi qu'il en coûte
aucune entreprise ne fera faillite
rassurez vous nous sommes là or on ne
peut pas durablement substituer de la
dette au travail le deuxième élément est
là je serai en désaccord avec olivier
c'est que je pense que l'europe à jouer
elle directement un rôle salvateur pour
l'économie française parce que on ne le
voit pas mais dans une situation où la
population s'appauvrit néanmoins elle
vit au dessus des moyens de la france
parce que la france ne travaillent pas
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que
vous avez un creusement spectaculaire
notre déficit de la balance des
paiements courants on a atteint sur les
trois premiers trimestres 50 milliards
d'euros
on est un peu revenue à des niveaux de
déficit de la balance des paiements qui
étaient ceux des années du début des
années 80 et de l'après plan de relance
de 80 et à l'époque on avait dévalué
imposer la rigueur là le choc a été
amortie par l'euro et donc d'une
certaine façon nous continuons à avoir
des taux d'intérêt très bas et à avoir
une capacité effectivement à absorber
des déficits extérieurs très élevé grâce
à l'euro alors il ya des gens qui disent
que c'est une bonne chose d'autre qui
disent que ça nous éloigne de notre
propre réalité et donc ça va finir par
se retourner contre nous mais à court
terme je pense que l'euro nous a permis
d'éviter un véritable drame économique
et social comme le dit aussi si bien
jean marc ça va nous retomber sur la
figure et malheureusement ça fera encore
plus mal parce que ça nous a en effet
permis de nous endetter essai c'est le
seul moyen qu'ils aient jamais trouvée
pour essayer de régler les problèmes
c'est la bête donc tout fonctionne
maintenant que là dessus et on en abuse
parce que les taux sont bas la seule
chose c'est que évidemment on est en
train de détruire systématiquement
l'économie réelle du pays avec ses taux
à zéro avec ce surcroît de dette
épouvantable et en se disant de toute
façon c'est pas grave on sauve le coup
là maintenant tout de suite et pour
après bah tant pis oui sauf que le après
ben tant pis risque de faire beaucoup
plus mal que si on avait laissé les
choses se faire et donc que non je ne
crois pas que l'euro soit une bonne
chose et je ne crois pas que l'union
européenne ait servi à quoi que ce soit
on a bien vu tout de même que depuis le
début de cette histoire c'est du chacun
pour soi et flag ont donc quand il ya un
souci contient un problème c'est chacun
pour sa pomme et à ce moment là le
l'europe ne sert strictement à rien sauf
à les expliquer les masques sur les
tarmacs ce qui est quand même pathétique
donc on n'est pas on n'est pas face à na
pas été brillants et ça n'a pas démontré
quoi que ce soit comme comme intérêt
pour fonctionner alors oui je vous la
corde la bce rachète absolument tout
mais on peut pas trouver c'est une bonne
solution non plus donc que oui à court
terme c mais c'est un emplâtre sur une
jambe de bois
alors jean magané l'olivier l'évoqué à
tout à l'heure on entend beaucoup
l'exécutif notamment parlé de 2022 comme
d'une année où la france
or pour est retrouvé les niveaux d'avant
qu'ovide 2020 a fait perdre à la france
9 % de son produit intérieur brut
jean marie danielle
un retour à la normale en 2022 ça vous
paraît probable après avoir vécu un tel
effondrement
écoutez c'est possible probable je suis
pas sûr que ce soit le mot on parlait de
la bce
christine lagarde qui avait eu la
prudence à vous m'en donnez de dire que
ce n'était pas elle qui vient au point
le vaccin est donc de considérer que
l'alpha et l'oméga de la solution
reposer sur l'action de la banque
centrale et sur son bazooka monétaire
était une illusion
et donc si lagarde dit on reviendra
effectivement une situation normale en
fonction de l'évolution de la maladie
plus on multipliera d'ici 2022 les
périodes de confinement et plus il sera
difficile de retrouver la situation 2019
en 2022 donc il ya deux ans je derrière
tout ça c'est la capacité que nous avons
à juguler ou à vivre avec la pandémie
parce que si on ne la juge il pas si on
considère que c'est à l'horizon de cinq
ou dix ans qu'on pourra arriver elle
retrouver une situation normale sur le
plan sanitaire
on va pas confiné tous les trois ou
quatre mois la population pendant dix
ans donc je pense qu'il ya une mode
d'organisation de la vie en société a
trouvé en fonction de l'évolution de la
situation sanitaire
puis le deuxième élément c'est que
puisqu'on parlait de guerre abandonné au
premier semestre jeu mettait en avant
les discours contenait au sortir de la
deuxième guerre mondiale et que au lieu
de parler d'eux dans le ville du conseil
de la résistance de revenir à un
discours célèbre de maurice thorez qui
avait été repris par la cgt il disait il
faut produire d'abord revendiqué ensuite
je pense qu'un appel à la mobilisation
du travail et n'appellent indispensable
c'est à dire que en 1944 1945
même si officiellement la durée du temps
de travail était de 40 heures on avait
demandé à la population de travailler
davantage et donc je crois que la
capacité de produire la capacité de
créer de la richesse et donc d'avoir la
croissance reposera sur la mobilisation
du travail et donc dans un certain
nombre de secteurs sur le fait de
travailler plus que les 35 heures
habituellement prévues par le code
actuel du travail olivier à vous
réagir est ce que vient de dire jean
marc daniel oui parce que c'est le sait
la phrase de bruno le maire qui dit que
les français travaillent pas assez mais
pour qu'ils travaillent
il faut pas les empêcher de travailler
parce que pour l'instant les français
travaillent il essaie en tout cas
travailler les seuls dont on n'a pas
l'impression qu'ils fassent grand chose
c'est nos ministres et nos députés
messieurs avant de passer aux prévisions
pour les 2021 on va marquer une courte
pause et on revient dans un instant
bienvenue dans ces caches si vous nous
rejoignez une émission à cette semaine
consacrée au bilan de l'année 2020 et
aux prévisions pour 2021 et pour cela
nous sommes en liaison avec jean marc
daniel économiste et professeur à escp
europe alors on va dorénavant se
concentrer sur l'année à 2021 avec vos
traditionnel scénario olivier il me
semble que vous en avait quelques-uns en
tête on va y aller avec le premier on
demandera ensuite son avis à jean-marie
d'année le premier c c'est d'abord une
prévision assez simple c'est à dire est
ce qu'on va être dans la continuité de
2020 ou pas il faut bien se rendre
compte que 2021 ça va être purement en
tout cas sur les deux premiers
trimestres
une catastrophe pourquoi parce
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez vous avez un
certain nombre de mécanismes qui ont été
mis en place le chômage partiel etc qui
a fait que le le
on a l'impression on a l'illusion que
les choses continuent et que c'est pas
c'est pas ça ne s'est pas en pires a pas
été un effondrement au dernier trimestre
l'effondrement vous allez l'avoir quand
tu auras plus ces mesures parce que
quand il aura pu ces mesures le chômage
partiel risque fort de se transformer en
chômage tout court
et là on va avoir réellement sur les
deux premiers trimestres les les effets
si vous voulez retard de ce qui s'est
passé du deuxième confinement est donc
d'abord on ne sait absolument pas quand
il va se terminer
pour l'instant donc faire des prévisions
sur 2021 de reprise et sur 2022 de
retour ce qu'on disait à l'instant de
retour au même niveau qu'avant 2020
c'est à mon avis tout à fait illusoire
donc voilà sur 2021 je dirais on peut
très bien continuer le ski s'est passé
en 2020 et les conséquences de ce qu'ils
sont passés en 2020 qui va être une
explosion du chômage qui va être donc
une chute de la consommation ça ça me
paraît assez clair et donc la poursuite
puis un certain nombre de faillites
et là vous pouvez avoir en effet des
conséquences importantes et jean lang
daniel une réaction vous comment est ce
que vous voyez 2021 je crois que
effectivement 2021 dépendra de la
réalité du déconfinement c'est à dire
que on nous avait annoncé le 11 mai que
nous allions être des confiné enfin nous
avait annoncé que le 11 mai serait la
date de déconfinement et dès que nous
avons été en partie des cons finale
puisque ça ne m'a pas été immédiat
l'activité économique a eu plutôt
tendance à reprendre assez vite
vous saviez décidé d'aider scénario que
l'on disait en uv w c'était à une
reprise lente ou une reprise en v
relativement rapide et en w une emprise
rapide mais assez vite plafond non en
fait certains ont parlé de reprise en y
c'est dire on avait plongé très
brutalement et on est reparti assez vite
pendant l'été pourquoi parce qu'il ya
deux éléments qui jouent le premier
élément c'est que le capital physique
n'a pas été détruit par rapport à une
guerre pour reprendre cette image dans
une guerre on rase les vides on rase les
ponts les routes tout le matériel qui
permet de travailler le produire là
c'est pas le cas dès qu'on remet les
gens dans les usines ils peuvent
produire et le deuxième élément qui
explique pourquoi ça a repris assez vite
c'est parce que les revenus ont été plus
ou moins consolider plus ou moins
préservé et donc même si partie la
population a vu son revenu est
incontestablement baissé on l'a vu avec
cette apparition du nez
une épargne forcée d'une épargne de
précaution assez élevé qui peut nourrir
cette consommation dont on a besoin
alors là où il faut être prudent c'est
premièrement beaucoup d'entreprises vont
faire faillite ça c'est clair les fonds
propres ont été laminés et donc la
première priorité ce sera de rétablir
les fonds propres de ces entreprises
il ya beaucoup de restaurants qui sont
maintenant au bord du dépôt de bilan et
même si les usines sont toujours là même
si les restaurants sont toujours là même
si les cuisines sont toujours là s'il ya
personne pour les faire tourner parce
que le propriétaire a fait faillite
effectivement la reprise sera pas au
rendez vous donc je crois qu'il faut
remettre en place un système des taux
fonds propres des entreprises qui
suppose des allègements fiscaux
considérables sur les entreprises et de
véritablement focaliser les forts de la
politique économique sur les entreprises
rapidement avant de refermer cette
émission on a beaucoup utilisé
l'expression à le monde d'après est ce
que finalement 2021 ce serait pas aussi
l'occasion de remettre un peu les
compteurs à zéro et de revoir nos
modèles économiques
jean daniel dans le monde d'après quand
le président de la république a beaucoup
utilisé cette expression
c'était dans son discours du 14 juin où
il a dit que le monde d'après serait
écologique
il serait solidaire et istres est
souverain et ça m'a beaucoup inquiété
parce que c'était à mon avis trois idées
farfelues ses dires écologique on l'a vu
il est en train d'essayer de se
dépatouiller de la convention citoyenne
sur le climat en essayant de raboter
systématiquement toutes les promesses
qu'il a pu faire souveraine c'est plus
ou moins appel à une forme de retour au
protectionnisme que je trouve assez
inquiétant et solidaire c'est un mois
c'est convenu dont on peut considérer
qu'il est en générale associée à
davantage de dépenses publiques
je crois que l'essentiel du monde
d'après c'est que ce monde après soit
plus libérale c'est à dire qu'on fasse
davantage confiance aux citoyens là on
joue rejoint olivier c'est quand même
qu'on nous a enfermés au nom d'une
maladie dont la dangerosité n'était pas
aussi évidente que ce qu'on a pu nous
dire au tout début on nous a enfermés
pendant 55 jours chez nous là on nous
menace de contrôler notre lot fêtes de
noël et on considère que 2021 devrait
continuer à être sur la même tendance
ça je trouve ça assez inquiétant olivier
même question pour terminer même
question jeu
la réponse va être assez proche c'est à
dire que comment voulez-vous de toute
façon changer avec les mêmes hommes aux
commandes
monsieur macron va pas changer de
logiciel demain matin ça n'arrive jamais
ça donc si vous voulez changer il va
falloir que les équipes changent et en
effet si vous voulez qu'à un moment on
nous on nous empêche pas de travailler
on nous empêche pas de vivre
merci olivier on va à présent à refermer
ce numéro spécial de ses caches merci
beaucoup je remarque daniel d'avoir
accepté une nouvelle fois notre
invitation
merci de m'avoir encore une fois merci
de m'avoir éviter merci à vous qui nous
regardent et sachez que toutes nos
précédentes émissions sont disponibles
sur notre site internet à l'adresse rt
france point tv n'oubliez pas pour la
prochaine émission à de poser toutes vos
questions à olivier sur les réseaux
sociaux avec le hashtag rt cash ou en
commentaire des vidéos on se retrouve
donc la semaine prochaine en attendant
je vous souhaite une très belle année
2021 olivier on se quitte avec votre
dernier mot souhaitons que rapidement
les équipes changent pour que le modèle
puis changer